keeping it simple in the kitchen doesn't
mean you can't have amazing food that
not only looks incredible but tastes
fantastic too
my first recipe is so easy it removes
the stress from cooking and it's a
pleasure to make chili beef lettuce
wraps
cooking should never be a chore the more
you cook the more confident you become
that way you actually start to enjoy it
and that's the key to good cooking have
a bit of fun along the way
this is minced beef and minced pork the
pork needs to sit in there otherwise the
beef's gonna dry out
it's really important to season the
mince before you cook it
pan nice and hot
a touch of olive oil
mince in
breaking up like that
really helps to sort of separate it so
we can fry it off with a lot of color
with your spoon
just go through
and start breaking that up
the most important thing to remember is
mint is made up of cheap cuts brisket
belly
short rib so
it needs help
and frying off the mince for color it's
so important
if this pan wasn't hot your mince is
going to boil
it's a horrible gray color on there
and there's no flavor on your mince
taste a little bit
[Music]
tastes delicious it's seasoned
beautifully see how crispy it's going
take it
much further than you ever taken mince
before nice and crispy
smells incredible
i'm draining it it's crucial it keeps
the mints nice and crispy and you get
rid of that
excess fat
that's lovely
now just wipe out the pan then wash it
low gas now we're going to add texture
to the mints
finely chopped chili
ginger
garlic and spring onions
spring onions give this sort of mince a
really nice freshness
because it just gives that crunch
nice and thinly
now i'm gonna fry off the chilies the
ginger and the garlic first
sesame seed oil teaspoon only in
garlic chili ginger in
fry that off nicely
the sesame seed oil just lifts up the
whole flavour
brown sugar that starts to really
caramelize the chili the garlic and the
ginger
mince in
now
my fish sauce that gives it the
saltiness
you can see now why it's so important to
get that mince really crispy because
nothing's going soggy staying really
crispy
fresh lime
that makes the mince fragrant
and then
lime juice roll it
and squeeze that in there
[Music]
incredible i've got the salty
i've got the heat
i've got the sweetness now i've got the
acidicness as well and then finally my
spring onions in right at the last
minute so i've got crunch in there as
well smells
amazing
literally cook the mince now with sort
of 30 seconds
to go
gas off and take it out
[Music]
looks incredible smells so inviting
[Music]
to go with the chili beef i'm making a
simple sweet and spicy dipping sauce so
everyone can dress the crispy mince to
their own taste
dipping sauce little teaspoon
the brown sugar soy sauce
gives it a nice sort of dark rich color
sesame seed oil
a tablespoon and just top that up with a
tablespoon
of olive oil that stops the sesame seed
all becoming too rich a teaspoon
of fish sauce and then a touch of chili
leave the seeds in again i want the heat
in that sauce
so impressive an amazing show off center
piece
lime juice in
in the coriander chop it through once
give that little mix up
just check the seasoning
that's lovely nice and rich
now the lettuce i'm going to use baby
gem because it's really nice and durable
and sort of quite strong
so you just sort of sit
these nice
trimmed lettuce leaves
around
now the exciting part to serve take your
lettuce up
spoon in
your mince and then a little touch of
dressing
just a little drizzle
nice and that's the secret of having
good easy relaxed food is that
you just help yourself
food that looks and tastes a million
bucks doesn't have to be complex
this dish is as fun to cook as it is to
eat
[Music]
one of the keys to keeping it simple is
to prepare all the ingredients in
advance the more organized you are in
the kitchen the easier cooking becomes
here are three of my favorite quick
recipes that with a bit of advanced
preparation are so simple to make
[Music]
starting with my easy fragrant fried
rice
first get prepped
chopped garlic
ginger and chilli
keeping the seeds for extra kick
slice spring onions
chopped spring greens and trim ahead of
broccoli
then whisk two eggs
prep done stir fry on
add a good lug of oil to a hot pan
garlic
ginger chili
next the spring greens and broccoli add
water to steam
[Music]
then cook rice
this dish is perfect for using leftover
rice
make a well
add the eggs
spring onions
and a dash of fish sauce
[Music]
scramble then mix
[Music]
season
[Applause]
top with lime and spring onions
[Music]
my fragrant fried rice
made simple with advanced prep and ready
in five minutes
my next recipe it pays to get prepped
for is garlic and saffron mayonnaise
[Music]
first get your ingredients to hand
eggs should be out of the fridge and at
room temperature
soak saffron in warm water
saffron is the most expensive spice in
the world made from the dried stigma of
crocus flowers
but even a pinch gives a fantastic taste
and a wonderful color
next separate three eggs put the yolks
into a mixing bowl
add dijon mustard
finely chopped garlic
the drained saffron
and a squeeze of lemon
then mix
whisk in constantly add oil slowly it
won't take forever
for perfect flavor use half olive oil
and half vegetable oil
when the mayonnaise comes together
season
[Music]
a smooth thick consistency means it's
done
top with saffron
rich delicious and perfect with
everything from seafood to sandwiches
and chips my second recipe
garlic and saffron mayonnaise easy to
get right as long as you've planned
ahead
my final dish that's a stinch to cook
with a little advanced prep work is
mussels with celery and chili
[Music]
first prep the veg chopped spring onions
shallots
a clove of garlic and chili to taste
then thinly slice celery
add a bay leaf and thyme
veg ready
[Music]
add oil to a pan and fry
[Music]
season
then add mussels and stir
mussels one of my favorite shellfish
cheap healthy and delicious
cover and sting for a couple of minutes
as the muscles open add vermouth and
aromatic 45 wine
[Music]
and 150ml of dry white wine
on a high heat reduce the liquid to
create a source
discard any muscles that are still shut
[Music]
then finish with creme fresh and chopped
parsley
[Music]
minimal prep and cooked in less than 10
minutes my muscles with celery and chili
impressive affordable and super speedy
make it simple in the kitchen by
prepping your ingredients in advance and
i promise you'll find these three
recipes a pleasure to make
amazing
you don't need to spend a fortune on
masses of kitchen equipment
this is my quick guide to kitchen knives
basically three knives a heavy duty
chopping knife
followed by a small paring knife which
is brilliant for prepping vegetables
and then this baby here a serrated edge
knife for carving and slicing
basically that is it
[Music]
before you buy a knife hold it in your
hand and make sure it feels right for
you
the secret behind a great set of knives
is in the handle if you're comfortable
holding the handle
your cutting can be so much easier the
firmer the grip the better the chopping
the heavier the handle the more control
you've got over the blade
with these three knives you can't go
wrong
my next recipe is easy and a pleasure to
make if you're organized with everything
ready in advance
[Music]
miso poached salmon with asian
vegetables
organization is key in the kitchen take
a couple of minutes before you start and
set yourself up make sure you know where
everything is
stock spatula pan etc it becomes less
stressful but more importantly the end
results are incredible
first off get your pan on
whisk
and stock
start off with this amazing fermented
soy bean puree
into the pan three nice tablespoons
gas on
now get your fish stock and whisk into
the puree
be generous with the stock
you want this nice
light
broth basically
you can buy miso paste from big
supermarkets and it works brilliantly
with salmon
poaching the salmon in the miso stuff
gives it a really nice sort of sweet
earthy creamy flavor it's incredible
bring it up to the bowl
i'm gonna infuse the broth and make it a
little bit more fragrant
kaffir lime leaf is very lemony inside
the miso broth
then chopped chili
chili's in
and finally sliced ginger
that's simmering beautifully
now we're gonna poach the salmon
poaching means cooking it in liquid but
it's cooked gently and the secret here
is to keep that salmon skin on if we
took the skin off now the salmon can
actually break up
whilst it's poaching
skin side down i'm just going to slide
that in
under
nice
the minute that's stopped
starts boiling turn it down let it
simmer
take a little ladle and just every
couple of minutes pour over
that makes sure the top of the salmon is
cooked evenly and keeps it nice and
moist
and poaching is one of the most delicate
ways of cooking so you have to handle it
with care
whilst the salmon's poaching in the miso
broth start preparing your vegetables
i'm using tender stem broccoli and bak
choy
i always like to cook the leaf and the
stem separately
the leaf is like sort of spinach and the
stem is so much thicker it's almost as
thick as a stick of celery so i like to
get the stems sliced
just so i've got that nice sort of
christmas
place the leaves together nicely roll
them up
nice and tight and then
slice them down
now my salad already
the flavor in that broth has been
elevated
now it tastes really fishy got the heat
the chilli spiciness the ginger and the
caffeine lime leaf
take your fish slice and place it very
gently underneath the salmon and push it
down fish slices are flexible for that
reason bend it
lift it up
just touch looking for a springy firm
texture and just
sit there on top
a little touch of the broth over it
it stops it from drying out
leave that to cool down for two minutes
bring the stock
back up to the boil broccoli and
bak choy stems in
a little taste
[Music]
it's getting better and better and
better
cook the broccoli and the bok choy stems
for one minute and then add the tops in
turn the salmon into your hand
and just peel all that skin off the skin
also
helps to keep the salad nice and moist
then gently flake the salmon that's the
secret behind
poaching everything just stays so moist
wonderful long shards of
pink now just before we serve
we're gonna add our mushrooms these are
enoki mushrooms
you can buy these enoki mushrooms in big
supermarkets and good grocers
slice them off i'm gonna put half in
and the other half i'll serve with the
salmon
toasted sesame seed oil put a little
drip in there just rub
and you're just lining almost like a
little coat of varnish start off with
your mushrooms and then my salmon
four nice layers
and then finally
the mushrooms
top with the vegetables and then finally
a nice ladle
that beautiful
really sumptuous
rich stock
lovely
and that is an amazing misu poached
salmon soup
simplify your cooking by getting
organized and amazing food will be
coming out your kitchen every day and
for great food you need great
ingredients
[Music]
next up my shopping guide to getting the
finest fish
when i buy my fish i only want the
freshest and the best
and if anyone knows how to get the best
it's roger kent barton he's been buying
and selling fish at the world famous
billings gate market in london for over
50 years
i love fish
i think it's the greatest food of all
time i sell literally every variety
there is i could feed you a different
fish
365 days a year this guy really knows
how to sniff out the good from the bad
all fish smell different the longer it's
around
the more fishy it will smell
when it's lovely and fresh
it doesn't smell whenever you're going
to buy fish don't be frightened get your
nose right into it don't go like that
get it into it smell it
smells delightful
it smells what i call salmony and it's
lovely barramundi it's a lovely fish the
way to tell good fish is look at it
closely it's shining it's still got the
bloom on it his eyes are as bright as
yours look in the gill lovely and red
put it in the bag for the gentleman
please people should always be asking
about their fish what kind of fish is it
where does it come from a nice salmon 19
pound it's a bargain at 20 pounds
roger's right salmon's brilliant value
and a great all-rounder really healthy
and super delicious here's a quick look
at the different cuts and how to use
them
[Music]
whole salmon always impresses it's
fantastic stuffed and steamed either in
a fish kettle or in the oven wrapped in
foil
steaks are great value and brilliant
baked
a cider salmon is perfect for poaching
home curing or baking in pastry
the fillet is so versatile easy fast to
cook and great for pan frying
smoked salmon delicious cooked or raw i
love it with scrambled eggs
broadly there's white fish and there's
oily fish they come under two different
sections here we have white fish
it's lovely it's cold it's the best cod
in the world it comes to a place called
peterhead it's nice and white
the whiter the better one of the most
oily fish you'll find mackerel there it
is
lovely color
with most fish the fresher they are the
harder they are if you're not well and
you're ill
have a macro
sprats otherwise known as top hats here
we have flat fish and these are known as
place as you can see they've got spots
the redder they are the fresher they are
it really is a lovely fish to eat king
jules couldn't have better for fish
fresh enough for royalty follow your
fishmonger's advice and you'll never
ever have another dodgy dover sole again
[Music]
next my tricks of the trade and kitchen
tips
first how to chop an onion this is the
root that's absolutely crucial leave
that on there if you cut that off the
onion will start to bleed and you'll
start crying rapidly
slice going forward let the weight of
the knife do the work
three fingers
one in front two behind and this part of
the knuckle is going to guide the knife
fingers on top of the onion point the
knife towards the root and try to get
as close to the root as possible nice
long
stroke
and then push the onion back together
push the knife halfway in to the onion
slightly tilt the knife down
one at the top
and then gripping the onion like a
tennis ball holding it together in place
with the weight of the blade to cut
through that onion to get to the base of
the root
again turn it round up and down motion
and that's what we're left there no
waste just the root
and look
there you've got a really nice finely
chopped onion
so much great cooking depends on
starting with a high enough heat if a
recipe calls for a hot pan put it on
early so it gets smoking hot and always
remember to preheat your oven at least
20 minutes before cooking
a clean cook is an efficient cook my tip
for a tidy cooking area is to always
have a waste bowl next to you it saves
you going back and forth to the bin
never add salt to eggs before cooking
them because it ruins the texture and
dulls the colour instead save your
seasoning to the very end
[Music]
the key to cooking meat is to make sure
it's at room temperature before you
begin cook straight from the fridge the
mussel fibres will be tight which
results in tough meat and always let it
rest afterwards so relax is becoming
tender and juicy
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stake your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details go on get cooking
you